sweet potato sweet potato toast whoo all
right folks let's top sweet potato toast
I mean it's super trendy they're saying
it's like the new avocado toast it's all
over Pinterest but it's a really toast
well you know I'm all for calling food
what it actually is I know that
cauliflower pizza is not actually pizza
and that zucchini noodles even though
they're super delish
they're not real pasta so sweet potato
toast I just don't know what else to
call it
bread is only bread into the Apapa in
the toaster so I say that sweet potatoes
can have the same title as long as
they've taken a little dip in that
appliance so today I'm gonna share three
awesome ways to make sweet potato toasts
that are gonna take your breakfast to
the next level let's do this okay guys
so to make sweet potato toast it's
actually really easy you want to just
start by peeling your sweet potatoes so
now we're just gonna cut it into about 1
5 millimeter slices then we just put it
into the toaster for a few rounds until
it gets tender and lightly golden okay
so first we're going to combine some
Greek yogurt with a little marmalade in
a small bowl so next I'm going to add a
little bit of honey to a nonstick
skillet over medium heat and I'm gonna
add some right slice bakes and let them
caramelize on both sides
and then we're just gonna finish these
off with a little bit of cracked black
pepper so first I'm gonna mix together
some cottage cheese with a little light
coconut milk I'm just gonna add a little
bit of coconut oil to a nonstick skillet
over medium heat and let that melt down
then I'm gonna add in a little bit of
curry powder next we're just gonna add
in some beautiful soft dried apricots
just let those toast in the curry powder
all right so first I'm going to mix
together some natural peanut butter
tamarind paste and a little lime juice
okay so next we're gonna fry an egg so
I'm just putting a little bit of
vegetable oil down I'm gonna crack it
all right
okay guys so I hope you really enjoyed
my free awesome take on sweet potato
toast I want to know in the comments
below what you would top your sweet
potato toast with do you want to go
sweet do you want to go savory give me
some inspiration below also don't forget
to subscribe to the channel you peez up
thumbs up if you like this video and
I'll see you next time on hobbies
kitchen